deeply make out his Rings leather
stiletto heels and a leather kind of
dress skirt thing and is dancing around
in a very sexualized posture and then
these total freak perverts on the side
are cheering him up
they're what are they cheering on
they're cheering on a sexual performance
of a 13 year old boy dressed in a tight
leather outfit
this isn't
well you know the slippery slope might
be slipping down this isn't some
conspiracy theory
idea there are there are Elite heados in
our culture and they have a lot of power
and you know you've got to talk to the
Illuminati and the rosicrucians and I
don't know some tin foil hat stuff
it's on video